londres
c'est la responsabilité de l'onu et du
conseil de sécurité notamment en la
personne de ses cinq membres permanents
mais vous savez ici c'est un cas très
pratique pour commencer à
critiquer
piétiner la politique américaine envers
oui c'est effectivement une catastrophe
ça c'est vrai c'est pas mes propos à moi
c'est les propos des analystes
américains eux mêmes c'est une
catastrophe parce que
s'il maintient ce sont des gens très
pragmatique
avait investi 1500 milliards de dollars
dans cette opération et que le résultat
est complètement nul si on regarde le
nom de gens qui ont été
abandonnés en afghanistan gens qui
travaillaient pour les alliés
occidentaux
il ya cette catastrophe humanitaire
en ce sens bien sûr
j'espère qu'il va y avoir une prise de
conscience
de reconsidération des positions
précédentes parce que
pour civiliser entre guillemets les
autres pays leur apporter les éléments
de
civilisation leur imposer ça
on voit que c'est une politique erronée
mais en fait on parle de l'exemple de
jeu de l'afghanistan on a les collègues
et qu'ils disent oui j'étais une faute
on a pu le faire
mais c'était déjà le cas
à l'époque de
des missionnaires catholiques qui venait
dans les pays asiatiques où par exemple
en chine et qui civilisé la population
locale en s'appuyant sur
les résultats des sciences de
l'enseignement de la médecine etc mais
le but n'était pas ça l'objectif était
de promouvoir le catholicisme
on voit pas beaucoup de changements là
c'est une colonisation qui est pas super
rituel mais
économique
mais c'était une tentative de maintenir
son influence en promouvant la
démocratie la démocratie si elle un
peuple en a besoin le peuple lui même va
y venir c'est pas la peine de lui
imposer par la force